als wir Oxana püschner treffen verteilt
sie erst mal Dosimeter die Geräte
zeichnen auf wie viel Strahlung wir
ausgesetzt sind oxanas Arbeitsplatz
liegt in Tschernobyl einem der
gefährlichsten Orte der Welt
alles hier ist radioaktiv verseucht auf
der Fahrt durch die Sperrzone erzählt
sie uns wie das war als der Krieg auch
nach Tschernobyl kam
ich habe einen Anruf bekommen der Krieg
hat angefangen und ich dachte das ist
ein Witz bis ich die ersten Hubschrauber
gesehen habe bis wir die Militär
Kolonnen gehört haben dann haben wir
verstanden dass das wirklich der Krieg
ist erst Wochen später wird die
29-Jährige nach Tschernobyl zurückkommen
das war vielleicht ein Anblick wir waren
daran gewöhnt dass das Sperrgebiet das
Territorium ist dass man ganz besonders
schützen muss und nach der russischen
Besatzung war es schwer mir vorzustellen
überhaupt am selben Ort zu sein
Oxana begleitet Besucher durch die
Sperrzone ihr ganzes Leben ist
Tschernobyl ihr Vater arbeitet hier ihr
Onkel war Liquidator einer der ersten
der nach dem Unfall im Reaktor 4 bei den
Löscharbeiten geholfen hat ein Sarkophag
bedeckt heute den Unglücksort die
Strahlung ist immer noch erhöht ein
Atomkraftwerk als Kriegsschauplatz für
Oxana eine beunruhigende Vorstellung
ist der Krieg nicht zu Ende ist kann
keiner sagen was noch geschieht deshalb
sind wir die ganze Zeit angespannt wir
fürchten uns davor dass doch noch was
passiert und wir versuchen alle zu
informieren dass das hier ein sehr
sensibles Objekt ist hier dürfen keine
militärischen Einsätze durchgeführt
werden
russische Panzer in Tschernobyl gleich
am ersten Kriegstag im Februar besetzen
Putin Soldaten das Atomkraftwerk und die
Sperrzone 200 Arbeiter die gerade
Schicht haben sind plötzlich Gefangene
der Betrieb der die Sicherheit der
stillgelegten Reaktoren garantiert läuft
einfach weiter erzählt uns der Leiter
des Werks
über einen Monat waren Sie hier
die Station setzte mit Hilfe der
Belegschaft die sich hier befand in
bestimmten Maß ihrer Arbeit fort
die Mitarbeiter müssen sicherstellen
dass keine neue Strahlung Austritt schon
bald aber reißt die Verbindung zu den
Überwachungsgeräten ab nichts wird mehr
aufgezeichnet auch die Stromversorgung
ist unterbrochen ein Dieselgenerator
muss tagelang überbrücken eine hoch
gefährliche Situation
jedes atomobjekt wird für das Leben in
Friedenszeiten und nicht für den Krieg
gebaut
und wenn wir den Reaktor oder das Lager
sprengen würden dann hätte das
katastrophale Folgen
der rote Wald erzählt uns Oxana ist der
Ort im Sperrgebiet der bei der
Katastrophe 1986 die höchste Strahlung
abbekommen hat erst wurden die Bäume rot
dann starben sie ab der Boden hier ist
extrem belastet
ausgerechnet hier würden die Russen die
Erde auf sie heben Schützengräben aus
schlagen ihr Lager auf Karten die die
tägliche Strahlenbelastung jedes
Soldaten dokumentieren sollen haben sie
zwar dabei nutzen sie aber nicht
ihre Karten die wir hier gefunden haben
die waren leer keine der Karten war
ausgefüllt
sie waren für jeden persönlich wer sie
waren der militärische Rang und die
Strahlungsdosis mit Datum bei ihnen
waren die alle leer
ihr Kollege
zeigt uns Stellungen der feindlichen
Panzer von hier aus haben die Russen und
Butcher mit Raketen beschossen die
Sperrzone von tschernoby diente ihnen
als Schutz
sie waren sich sicher dass Ukrainer sie
hier nicht angreifen werden der Grund
das hätte möglicherweise Staub
aufgewirbelt und der wäre gefährlich
gewesen nicht nur für die Ukraine
sondern auch für Europa wegen der
Wetterbedingungen
staub kann überall fliegen
nach gut einem Monat ziehen sich die
Russen zurück verlassen auch die Stadt
Tschernobyl die ebenfalls in der
Sperrzone liegt 98 Einwohner gibt es
hier die die nie weg wollten
so wie Halina wo losina sie ist 74 hat
ihr ganzes Leben hier verbracht mit der
Strahlenbelastung hat sie zu leben
gelernt sagt sie als die Russen kamen
hat sie sich um die Radioaktivität die
wenigsten Sorgen gemacht
nein ich hatte keine Angst wir haben uns
an all das schon gewöhnt wie man so sagt
die Einwohner in tschernoby haben keine
Angst vor Strahlung wir haben keine
Angst vor Strahlung wir essen alles aus
unserem Gemüsegarten wir sammeln Pilze
und Bären wir fangen Fische
der Krieg macht dir schon Angst sie muss
weinen als sie uns von ihrem Sohn
erzählt er kämpft den bachmut während
der Besatzung wurde Halina immer wieder
von russischen Soldaten bedroht
anfangs konnte ich das nicht glauben bis
15 Leute einen Monat lang mit
Maschinengewehren zu mir kam um nach
meinem Sohn zu suchen der in Don Bass
Krieg war zwei bis dreimal täglich kamen
sie
auf einem zentralen Platz der Stadt
zeigt uns Oxana die Schilder die an die
verlassenen Dörfer der Todeszone
erinnern
manchmal für das Leid so vielerlei dass
der Krieg jetzt wieder in die Ukraine
gebracht hat
wenn man uns sagt morgen ist der Krieg
zu Ende dann sage ich das wäre gut wenn
man nicht weiß wann das Ende ist wenn
man das Ende nicht sieht dann ist es
sehr schwer
Leben mit der atomaren Bedrohung Leben
mit dem Krieg in Tschernobyl müssen sie
mit beidem fertig werden